hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen serie die ich
mir überlegt habe die extrem dumm ist
hier oben rechts stand übrigens gerade
produktplatzierung weil wieso ist mein
haar hier die das fällt mir immer da
oben starker produkt das ihr das video
unterstützt durch eine produktion und
ich warte einfach ab
die neue serie die ich mir ausgedacht
hat ist die pea dd
ja kann man sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
nichts drunter vorstellen dann alle
diese idee die an ich kenne das ist die
website mit diesem logo hier das ist
quasi wikipedia in dumm
glaubt eine bessere erklärung dafür gibt
es nicht man kann dort alle möglichen
begriffe suchen und bekommt nicht so wie
bei wikipedia so einen richtig guten
artikel dazu sondern so einen komplett
bescheuerten und das machen wir den
ersten begriff den ich einfach mal ein
gäbe ist youtube gebe ich mal ein auch
90 3 1 und das erste was vorgeschlagen
wird es youporn
da sehen wir wo wir gelandet sind
youtube englisch youtube nicht zu
verwechseln mit die zahnpasta tube ist
ein schimpfwort für leute die wie ihre
mit ihrem camper oder durch die gegend
laub und alles will was ich hinfiel
insel trifft sich das ganze filmmaterial
auf die festplatte versehen es mit
psychedelische musik und lacht
was allerdings noch lange nicht heißt es
ist deswegen noch verfügten im alter
auch nice hier werden häufige kommentare
angegeben hey wo der typ da die frau bei
640 aufschlitzt voll billiger trick
beruf denkst oh mein gott cool ich
wusste gar nicht dass man mit einem
konter für so viel machen kann hoch v
sie wird auch als häufiger kommentar
gesagt erster und direkt darunter vor
diese erster sarah gehen mir so was von
auf den sack und direkt darunter wtf
2204 unterbewertungen aber nur 300 als
aufrufe trifft einfach komplett auf dem
boden hier ist außerdem auch ein
typischer julians blog kommentar und
zwar da bist so arm ich du kopfschuss
scheißen [ __ ] [ __ ] sperma in der
fei
das ist wirklich ein linksblock
kommentar das nächste was wir uns jetzt
mal anschauen ist pizza wenn ihr meine
social media aktivitäten und haben und
auf twitter verfolgt wird dir dass ich
pizza liebe das sieht man beispielsweise
diesem tweet oder auch an diesem tweet
oder an diesem tweet oder auch an diesem
tag unter anderem dann auch an diesem
tweet
und dann habe ich auch letztes mal den
spiel rausgehauen an alle pizza
unternehmen kriege ich ein placement für
pizza bitte liebe grüße luca
und das ist das heutige placement ihr
müsst euch vorstellen ich bin hier so
nichts ahnend vor einigen tagen an den
pc ich stelle einfach mal nach video
hier auf
als tester in halo luca wir haben deinen
tweet bezüglich des pizza places auf
twitter gelesen und würden die dieses
gerne anbieten herzliche grüße dr oetker
nein spaß es nur eine einkaufsliste ja
gut freunde ein bisschen anders was
schon aber ich habe die möglichkeit
bekommen ein placement für den pizza
burger zu machen
der sieht nicht immer so aus aber
eigentlich hab den ganzen an in der
verpackung aber ich habe vorher schon
voll viel davon gefressen ich habe mir
hier den barbecue schicken geholt glaube
ich und habt ihr dann einfach elf
minuten im ofen kurz warm gemacht es war
relativ schnell fällig und kann jetzt
hier mit einer hand essen wir dass da
irgendwas tropft was eigentlich schon
ganz neues da wir jetzt quasi pizza
eingegeben hatten dachte ich ich kann
das ganz gut mit diesem stück idee via
video hier heute verbinden und der
schmeckt halt echt gar apropos placement
wenn ich andere youtuber sehe die
4players in einem video hingekriegt
haben
bb wie schaffst du vier placement in
einem video habe ich mir gedacht ich
trete so oft über pizza und ich liebe
pizza warum nicht
ich glaube ich esse netzaufbau pizza
burger southwest meine lieben freunde ja
es war ein placement aber ich find
besser hält sich passen könnte ich liebe
pizza und ich stehe voll und ganz hinter
aber wir machen jetzt weiter mit dem
video gesagt hielt sich bei der pizza in
erster linie um einen vor allem bei
jugendlichen beliebte gemisch aus
verschiedensten gift zu scheiße
zusammenfassend kann man sagen eine
pizzas eingenommen pfannkuchen freunde
will sogar der pizza burger erwähnt bis
auf einen pizza burger der ist ein gut
gelungener pfannkuchen burger
ok pizza wird aus ketchup mayonnaise und
papier hergestellt bei 50 kommt auch
noch dazu
ich wollte unbedingt vor der kamera was
mich als bielefelder noch mehr
interessieren würde wäre was passiert
wenn ich arminia bielefeld dort ein gebe
bei arminia bielefeld ist ein minder
bekannter fußball club der als füllstoff
zwischen den einzelnen bundesligen hin
und herpendelt der kleine club aus
ostwestfalen gilt als eines der
hauptopfer des gefürchteten fahrstuhl
magnetismus und spielt momentan in der
ersten ein zwei oder doch erst jetzt ist
doch wieder in der zweiten liga na ja
jetzt nicht mehr weiter nur noch
regionalliga oder vielleicht doch nicht
wer weiß das schon
magst du pd die ja nicht ich schließe
das jetzt an dieser stelle werde ich
auch das video meine lieben freunde ich
weiß war es nicht allzu lang geworden
allerdings ist bei solchen videos immer
so genau so wie bei dem fc fan video was
ich euch hier mal verlinke da muss ich
halt immer ultra viel schneiden mit den
ganzen keyframes wo das dann so hin und
her fährt und dann wenn ich texte zeigen
und ein stopp und und das dauert mich
immer irgendwie vier stunden im schnitt
deswegen verzeiht mir das des videos
nicht irgendwie sieben oder acht minuten
geht vielleicht geht's dass er so gar
keine ahnung und ich hoffe ihr seid mir
nicht ich sag mal böse dass ich jetzt
eine produktplatzierung gemacht habe
weil er ja oft viele leute rummeckern
von wegen produktplatzierungen es ist
ein echtes produkt was ich selber feiert
jeder der mich kennt weiß dass ich pizza
über alles liebe und ich habe mir jetzt
sogar gerade schon hier den zweiten
bürger von unten geschnappt weil jeder
verpackung sind irgendwie zwei drin das
ist mir aber erst beim aufmachen
aufgefallen
bis stark und dann würde ich sagen wenn
ihr noch einen zweiten teil zu media
haben wollt wo ich mir dann andere
sachen anschauen dann schreibt den
begriff in die kommentare und gibt
norman hoch wenn ihr das wollt und wir
sehen uns
wir sehen uns